quite a few thoughts firstly what
progress has been made in string theory
in the past say two decades
yeah okay well that's a a nice big chunk
of time and I'd say you know the the big
thing in the last two decades has been
the the recognition
that
there's a connection between gravity and
quantum mechanics
that I don't think we sufficiently
appreciated 20 25 years ago I mean I
mean take my book just as As One Moment
In Time a snapshot in the elegant
universe as published in 1999.
and in that book I I very clearly lay
out there's this Theory called general
relativity describing Gravity the big
stuff
I lay out how there is this other Theory
called quantum mechanics describing the
small stuff and we want to put them all
together to have a unified theory of the
Big M the small but we're having trouble
doing that and then I go into the book
and how String Theory seems to be making
progress in putting the big and the
small together if I was writing that
book today and in some sense I am
because I'm adding a chapter for the
25th anniversary of the elegant universe
and and one of the things that I'm
emphasizing is
there's now a lot of evidence
that gravity and quantum mechanics in
some sense
are kind of the same Theory they
are already in some strange sense
combined and this was completely
unexpected based on anything that we
knew 20 or so 20 plus years ago so
within for instance general relativity
there are these structures you made
reference to one of them earlier called
wormholes which are tunnels in the
fabric of space going from one
space-time location to another through a
kind of shortcut that's general
relativity and quantum mechanics there's
this weird thing called quantum
entanglement where two widely separated
particles can act as though they're
right next to each other even though
they can be on opposite ends of the
universe
and really nobody thought there was a
connection between these two ideas until
people like Lenny suskind and Juan
Maldives and a variety of other
influential scientists too many to name
them all
gave evidence that in some sense
wormholes and entanglement are kind of
the same thing they kind of feel the
same if you think about it
Wormhole it's connecting one point in
space-time with another through a
shortcut entanglement is connecting one
particle in space time with another
particle in some sense through a
shortcut because they're acting as
though they're right next to each other
and so this is the beginning the tip of
an iceberg of a deep and and very
powerful story which is showing that
structures and general relativity and
structures in quantum mechanics are
already deeply connected and deeply
entwined and so the unification program
May ultimately not be described in terms
of putting gravity and quantum mechanics
together the way I described it and many
did of course in the earlier days but it
may be more deeply understanding general
relativity more deeply understanding
quantum mechanics and more deeply
understanding how they are part and
parcel of the same theoretical structure
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy